professor lars schaade und ganz außen
den präsidenten der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin vor jansens
links neben mir begrüße ich den
vorstandsvorsitzenden des vereins der
labormediziner doktor michael müller und
daneben sehen sie noch einen freien
platz der hoffentlich und in dieser
veranstaltung noch gefüllt wird von der
arbeitsgruppenleiter dann des helmholtz
zentrums für infektionsforschung
professor melanie brinkmann sie ist so
habe ich gerade erfahren am bahnhof
angekommen steckte kurzem zug fest wird
aber noch hier sein und dann auch
voraussichtlich für fragen zur verfügung
stellen alle halten kurze statements
danach ist zeit für ihre fragen und es
beginnt herr sparen sie haben das wort
liebe frau busch meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren nicht denn angesichts
der islamistischen terror anschläge in
frankreich und gestern in wien
erschüttert ich wünsche den verletzten
eine schnelle genesung den familien den
angehörigen der getöteten gehört unser
aller beileid
europa erlebt eine terrorwelle mitten in
der pandemie bei beiden gilt es
solidarisch zu sein und gemeinsam
dagegen anzukämpfen
wir brauchen eine strategie gegen den
islamismus müssen hinschauen auf
strukturen die diesen terror ermöglichen
und sie bekämpfen und wir müssen diesen
kampf im schulterschluss mit den
liberalen muslimen führen meine damen
und herren ich setze heute hier nicht
nur als bundesminister für gesundheit
sondern auch als wieder genesener cupid
19 patienten
ich hatte zu jeder zeit zum glück ein
eher milden verlauf ich danke meinen
berliner gelungen gesundheitsamt hier
vor ort und den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern dort die einen unglaublich
professionellen und engagierten job
gemacht haben und weiterhin machen und
das schon seit monaten das habe ich als
patient und als bürger erlebt und eben
nicht wie sonst in der diskussion als
minister diese pandemie ist eine echte
mammutaufgabe für uns als regierung und
für jeden und jeden einzelnen in der
gesellschaft
seit acht monaten arbeiten wir gemeinsam
daran das virus einzudämmen
und nach allem was wir wissen haben wir
den höhe
diese aufgabe noch nicht erreicht wir
sind in einer entscheidenden phase
die lage ist ernst es geht um eine
nationale kraftanstrengung es geht um
eine gemeinsame kraftanstrengung
viele menschen leiden unter dieser
pandemie sie sind krank
sie sind in quarantäne sie haben sorge
sich anzustecken
sie müssen sich in ihrem freizeit in
ihrem privaten verhalten massiv
einschränken und viele haben
nachvollziehbare sorge um ihre
wirtschaftliche existenz krone ruft
starke emotionen in unserer gesellschaft
hervor
bei uns allen deswegen saß die kanzlerin
gestern am ersten tag der neuen chor
ohne auflagen hier
und deswegen sind wir hier heute an
selber stelle um sie uns ihren fragen
erneut uns zu stellen ich danke allen
expertinnen und experten dass sie dabei
mithelfen frau bringt man die sich ja
gleich noch zu uns stoßen wird als
virologin herr janssens als
intensivmediziner herr müller als
labormediziner und der professor schade
als vizepräsident des robert koch
instituts es geht darum die lage
realistisch einzuschätzen zu erklären
warum dieses erneute herunterfahren des
öffentlichen lebens notwendig ist und
wie sich das einfügt in unsere corona
strategie dieses virus ist tückisch es
lässt keine einfachen antworten zu wir
müssen vielmehr immer wieder unsere
strategie an die lage anpassen so auch
jetzt und das ist übrigens teil der
strategie in einer dynamischen lage
gehört das anpassen an die lage zur
strategie um die pandemie im griff zu
behalten mussten wir die notbremse
ziehen
denn wenn die gesundheitsämter die
infektion nicht mehr nachverfolgen
können gewinnt das virus jeden tag
weiter an schrecken und das wollen wir
nicht zulassen
die härte der chor ohne auflagen sollen
nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass wir
auch an ganz vielen anderen stellen
diese pandemie gezielt bekämpfen
unser augenmerk gilt dabei vor allem den
schutz derjenigen die besonders stark
vom virus betroffen sind den älteren den
pflegebedürftigen und den menschen mit
vorerkrankungen
deswegen haben wir die test verordnung
angepasst
deswegen stellen die schnelltests zu
pflegeheime und krankenhäuser zur
verfügung
deswegen bereiten wir die impfung
zunächst für besonders vom virus
betroffenen gruppen vor
deswegen versorgen wir pflegeheime und
pflegedienste zusätzlich mit
schutzmasken die neue quarantäne
verordnung für rückkehrer aus
risikogebieten die am 8 11 in kraft
tritt ist ein weiteres beispiel dafür
wie wir dieser pandemie begegnen eben
nicht nur durch dein herunterfahren des
öffentlichen lebens sondern auch durch
präzise regeln die uns helfen mit dem
virus zu leben leben zu lernen
unser ziel bleibt es eine balance zu
finden zwischen dem was nötig ist und
dem was möglich ist und das so lange bis
es einen impfstoff oder eine therapie
gibt dieser jahrhundert pandemie
erfordert besonders in einem bereich
eine nationale kraftanstrengung es ist
einer der sensibelsten bereiche unserer
gesellschaft unser gesundheitswesen als
bundesminister für gesundheit macht es
mich stolz und vor allem dankbar
mit welchem engagement sich die vielen
beschäftigten im gesundheitswesen dem
kampf gegen das virus jeden tag stellen
und das schon seit vielen monaten ein
pflegerinnen und pflegern den
reinigungskräften den ärztinnen und
ärzten den mitarbeitern in den laboren
allen die jeden tag im gesundheitswesen
mit helfen ein herzliches dankeschön
sie sind die helden unserer zeit ihnen
zu helfen und sie zu schützen das muss
unser aller ziel sein
unser gesundheitssystem war bis hierhin
zu keiner zeit überfordert und doch gibt
es nichts zu beschönigen die lage ist
ernst die zahl der infizierten steigt
exponentiell
und auch die zahl derjenigen die beatmet
werden müssen steigt stark zu stark und
ich nehme sehr wohl die sorge der
intensivmediziner lieberherr janssens
war die vor überfüllten station vor
überlasteten ärztinnen und ärzten und
pflegekräften waren
wir werden die krankenhäuser
unterstützen wo wir können keine klinik
soll wegen corona wirtschaftlich
benachteiligt sei
wir werden mit den ländern darüber
sprechen wie wir die kapazitäten noch
weiter zielgerichtet besser steuern
können wir haben erfahrungen damit aus
den anfangszeiten dieser pandemie und
die nutzen wir nun darüber habe ich auch
gestern mit den 16 kolleginnen und
kollegen aus den ländern gesprochen die
pandemie wird uns allen noch viel
abverlangen doch wir wissen wie wir
unsere kräfte einteilen können und
einteilen müssen die vorübergehenden
kontakt beschränkungen sind hart für
alle
das wird das ist ein harter november
aber er kann und wird helfen das virus
wieder besser in den griff zu bekommen
dass wir dann trotzdem noch vorsichtig
sein müssen auch nach diesem november
das liegt auf der hand
dabei kann jeder mitmachen die auflagen
beachten und aufeinander achten
denn am ende kommt es auf uns als
gesellschaft an kommt es auf jeden
einzelnen an
auf sie ganz persönlich kommt es an
dieses virus gemeinsam zu bekämpfen
jeder von uns kann einen unterschied
machen wir sind diesen virus nicht
machtlos ausgeliefert wir wissen wie es
geht vor allem auch im alltag geht
lassen sie uns diese nationale
kraftanstrengung gemeinsame welt danke
dafür in der zwischenzeit angekommen und
deswegen auch noch mal ein herzliches
willkommen
ein professioneller in die bringt man
als nächstes steht aber zunächst das
wort herr schade
sehr geehrte damen und herren aufgrund
der aktuell ernsten lage müssen wir uns
alle im november wieder enorm
einschränken
umfragen zeigen dass viele von ihnen
einschränkende maßnahmen aber auch
zunehmend unterstützen
sie wissen dass kontakt beschränkungen
helfen das virus einzudämmen und
reduzieren ihre persönlichen kontakte
deutlich ich möchte ihnen einen vorab
dafür danken dass sie sich damit
gegenseitig schützen
das infektionsgeschehen in deutschland
nimmt seit einigen wochen rasant zu aber
wir müssen und können es bremsen
wir müssen verhindern dass sich das
virus weiter unkontrolliert ausbreiten
kann
lassen sie uns einen blick auf die
entwicklung werfen seit beginn der
pandemie bis heute wurden dem rk ii
insgesamt 560.000 379
mit 19 fälle übermittelt darunter zehn
1661 todesfälle
wir schätzen dass etwa 371 1500 menschen
die akute infektion überstanden haben
wie ist die lage zurzeit einzuschätzen
und woran erkennen wir dass da sind die
fallzahlen die in den letzten monaten
immer schneller angestiegen sind
anfang oktober wurden täglich zwischen
1000 und 4000 fälle an das robert koch
institut übermittelt
ein monat später sind wir bei im schnitt
15.000 fällen pro tag angekommen
die anzahl der fälle hat sich zuletzt
innerhalb von zehn tagen verdoppelt wenn
das genau so weiter ginge hätten wir bis
weihnachten über 400.000 gemeldeten
neuinfektionen pro tag
und denken sie bitte daran dass wir
niemals alle fälle erfassen können
so sind die tatsächlichen zahlen sogar
noch höher als die die wir uns
letztendlich ausweisen welche weiteren
kenngrößen helfen uns die entwicklung
einzuschätzen und zu verstehen
bundesweit liegt zum beispiel die sieben
tage incidents pro 100.000 einwohner
derzeit bei 124,2 fällen
das heißt dass aktuell pro woche 124 von
100.000 menschen in deutschland als
infiziert gemeldet werden der sogenannte
erwert oder die reproduktions zahl lag
seit anfang oktober deutlich über 1 das
bedeutet dass ein infizierter im schnitt
mehr als eine andere infektion person
angesteckt hat auch wenn der wert in den
letzten tagen eine leicht sinkende
tendenz zeigt einige menschen stecken
dabei niemanden oder nur sehr wenige an
andere aber stecken sehr viele menschen
an solche situationen zu verhindern ist
besonders wichtig und vorab wissen wir
ja nicht ob wir zu den sogenannten super
spendern gehören oder nicht
wir können es aber beeinflussen ob wir
zu solchen werden indem wir unsere
kontakte zu anderen personen reduzieren
zusammenkünfte vermeiden und uns stets
an die aha + l regeln halten
bitte tun sie dies im privaten bereich
aber eben auch im arbeitsleben und
nutzen sie waren immer möglich das home
office
welche weiteren zahlen sind wichtig es
werden aktuell 2243 patienten
und patientinnen intensivmedizinisch
behandelt noch können wir alle versorgen
noch reicht das medizinische personal
aber auch unser gesundheitssystem hat
seine grenzen zwischen ansteckung und
krankenhaus eintritt vergehen einige
tage von den aktuell hohen fallzahlen
werden wir also in circa acht bis zehn
tagen viele dann auf der intensivstation
betreuen müssen
daher sind diese intensivierten
maßnahmen notwendig weil wir uns eben in
einem sogenannten exponentiellen
wachstum befinden das bedeutet natürlich
dass auch die anzahl schwerer fälle also
die anzahl der menschen die
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
ebenfalls exponentiell stand dieses
überlastete mit der zeit jedes
gesundheitssystem und wir müssen
natürlich auch mit weiteren todesfällen
rechnen
aber wir können etwas tun die maßnahmen
können das virus bremsen jede und jeder
kann beten seine verbreitung zu
verlangsamen
damit wird die kontrolle zurück erlangen
dann können die maßnahmen auch wieder
zurückgefahren kann und es wird auch
wieder eine zeit kommen in der wir uns
freier bewegen werden die chancen auf
einen baldigen impfstoff sind
realistisch es laufen viel versprechende
studien mit diesen neuen impfstoffen
wenn diese studien zeigen dass die neuen
impfstoffe sicher und auch wirksam sind
und ein großteil der bevölkerung gegen
coop 19 geimpft ist wird das die
situation ändern
viele menschen zu impfen dauert aber
seine zeit bis dahin müssen wir
erreichen das ist zu wenig todesfällen
schweren erkrankungen und folgeschäden
möglich kommt das ist uns bisher
insgesamt gut gelungen darauf bauen wir
auf wir halten uns alle gemeinsam an die
hs.r regeln wir reduzieren unsere
kontakte wir sind noch mitten im
marathon
aber wir schaffen das gemeinsam dank
kooperationen und solidarität und es
gibt noch viele dinge die wir über das
virus nicht noch nicht wissen es gibt
unsicherheiten das muss man klar sagen
aber wir wissen und kommen können
zunehmend mehr je höher die fallzahlen
desto schwieriger wird es alle personen
mit atemwegsinfektionen zu testen
im herbst und winter nehmen diese ja
auch unabhängig von corona durch andere
viren zu um alle personen mit
erkältungssymptomen zu testen müssten
wir wöchentlich mehr als drei millionen
durchführen das ist weder möglich noch
erforderlich um die laborkapazitäten
nicht zu überlasten und um möglichst
effektiv zu testen haben wir daher
unsere empfehlungen für ärzte war ein
test bei personen mit
erkältungskrankheiten durchgeführt
werden sollte angepasst
hierbei spielen drei faktoren eine rolle
die symptomatik zb schwerer husten
fieber atemnot und störungen des geruchs
und geschmackssinn zweitens die frage ob
die symptomatische person oder die ihre
kontaktperson aus den risikogruppen
stammen und drittens die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die personen den
virus ausgesetzt war positiv getestete
personen werden isoliert ihre kontakte
er wenn möglich ermittelt informieren
sie aber bitte auch ihre kontakte
möglichst schnell selbst wichtig ist
dass auch menschen die trotz ihrer
symptome nicht getestet werden können
verhindern sollten andere menschen
anzustecken
sie sollten sich bitte fünf tage
isolieren und ihre isolation danach erst
beenden wenn sie weitere 48 stunden ohne
symptome waren sollten sich die symptome
verschlechtern sollten sie sich testen
lassen
vielen dank als nächstes hat das wort
frau brinkmann ja ich habe kein skript
vorbereitet ich dachte ich rede einfach
mal so frei heraus
dieses virus macht uns allen das leben
schwer
allen die die infiziert werden aber auch
denen die gar nicht infiziert werden
dadurch dass wir maßnahmen treffen
müssen die dieses virus eindämmen und
dass das liegt einfach daran an der
eigenschaft dieses virus
ja es macht eben nur ein paar leute
schwer krank aber es verbreitet sich
sehr leicht und dadurch dass es viele
menschen nicht so stark erkrankten lässt
laut bewegen die sich frei herum und
nehmen sich natürlich nicht zurück warum
sollten sie auch sie merken ja gar nicht
dass sie infiziert sind und genau das
macht es so schwer dieses virus
einzudämmen es ist eigentlich viel
gefährlicher als ein virus was menschen
richtig
macht denn die bleiben zu hause und
stecken wie manchen an und dadurch kann
das virus nicht weiter verbreitet werden
und es ist leider so dass dieses virus
uns immer wieder zwingen wird in so eine
situation zu kommen in der wir jetzt
sind wir müssen es wir müssen die wellen
brechen wir müssen das exponentielle
wachstum stoppen das wird immer wieder
dazu kommen in nächster zeit und das ist
gerade das was dieses virus gefährlich
macht und ich bin es ehrlich gesagt
etwas leid wir haben den sommer damit
verschwendet darüber zu diskutieren wie
gefährlich ist das eigentlich
funktionieren eigentlich die pcr tests
ich erzähl doch auf dem automechaniker
nicht wo der motor am auto ist was
reparieren soll ja wir müssen jetzt
glaube ich wirklich uns klar machen was
wir erreichen wollen was sind unsere
ziele wir wollen dafür sorgen dass die
medizinische versorgung für alle
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
funktioniert deshalb müssen jetzt diese
welle brechen
wir wollen alle eine schnelle
wirtschaftliche erholung die werden wir
nicht haben wenn die zahl der
infektionen weiterhin steigt das ist ja
ein trugschluss und das ist glaube ich
allen die hier sitzen auch völlig klar
und auch vielen die mir zu hören
wir müssen sicherstellen dass die
schulen geöffnet bleiben auch das können
wir nur in denen wir jetzt bremsen und
wir wollen natürlich auch krankheit und
sterben zahlen reduzieren wir reden
immer nur von den oder häufig von den
menschen die sterben aber wir müssen
auch an die menschen denken die
erkrankten und sehr lange zeit brauchen
sich zu über sich wieder zu erholen
von daher sollten uns jetzt darauf
konzentrieren lösungen zu finden
konstruktive lösung pragmatische lösung
und dafür müssen wir jetzt diese zeit
nutzen die wir uns gerade erkaufen durch
diesen lockdown und wir werden jetzt
gleich janssens wird darauf eingehen
über die zahl der intensivbetten
sprechen und ich frage mich manchmal
über was reden wir hier eigentlich ja
wir wollen doch eigentlich diese
intensivbetten gar nicht
das sind schwer kranke menschen die dort
versorgt werden eigentlich wollen wir da
gar nicht hin ich sage ja auch nicht wir
brauchen kein anschnallgurt mehr weil
uns solche sorgen dass mittlerweile echt
gut drauf haben leute zusammenzuflicken
das kann ja das ist ja völlig absurd ja
diese argumentation wir wollen diese
betten eigentlich erst gar nicht füllen
also ist die prävention eigentlich das
beste was wir in der hand haben und die
müssen wir verbessern die ist nicht
optimal da ist vieles da ist viel luft
nach oben ich beschreibt das immer gerne
mit einem schweizer käse modell ich weiß
nicht ob sie das kennen der schweizer
käse modell besagt dass jede scheibe
käse löcher hat das sind in perfektion
und jetzt stellen sie sich die maßnahmen
die wir in der hand haben die hhl regeln
aber auch dass contact tracing die neuen
anti gen tests die impfungen das sind
alles neue käsescheiben die alle ihre in
perfektion haben aber wenn wir die alle
hintereinander schalten können wir uns
immer besser vor diesem virus schützen
wir können uns auch darin schützen indem
wir löcher verkleinern dass contact
racing zum beispiel das müssen wir jetzt
wieder in den griff bekommen aber wir
müssen uns auch verbessern
wir müssen da einfach schneller werden
wir laufen ja immer hinterher
und da müssen wir schlauer werden und
uns jetzt die nächsten wochen da ganz
klare neue konzepte entwickeln
sodann wollte ich auch noch mal schon
noch mal auf die intensivbetten gehen um
noch mal auf zu begründen warum brauchen
wir diesen wellenbrecher wir sehen in
den ländern um uns herum auch länder die
gesagt haben wir werden keinen lockdown
mehr haben gehen jetzt in den lockdown
weil sie nicht mehr anders können weil
ein gesundheitsnotstand besteht und
viele länder kommen in dieser situation
was heißt triage triage ist etwas was
wir aus dem krieg kennen
das heißt der arzt kriegt mehrere
patienten schaut die sich an und sagt
wer hat die beste chance durchzukommen
der darf als bergungsgerät die anderen
haben pech gehabt da wollen wir nicht
hinkommen und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir jetzt bremsen besser
wäre es gewesen wir hätten noch früher
gebremst
und ich glaube wenn wir jetzt alle wenn
wirklich nicht nur 80 prozent mitmachen
wie verrät zeit habe ich eigentlich
müssen wir unterbrechen ist als erstes
dadurch ist nach oben kommen und ich
schon viele fragen fragen was sorgen
wird also dann schließe jetzt damit wenn
nur 80 prozent mitmachen ist das schon
nicht schlecht das ist ja auch das was
wir sehen die bevölkerung geht mit und
versteht es auch aber noch besser wäre
es natürlich 100 prozent mitmachen denn
dann dauert dieser ganze leid lockdown
einfach auch kürzer ja dann sind die
dann sind diese ganzen einschränkungen
die für kein schön sind einfach kürzer
und ja und jeder selbst derjenige der
mann in das virus nicht glaubt ja dem
ich zehnmal erklären kann das ist virus
existiert selbst der wird verstehen dass
es ihm nutzt wenn er jetzt mit macht und
wir alle uns an die regeln halten und
unsere kontakte so weit es geht
reduzieren
danke dafür herr jan sind als nächstes
wird ja wohl schon lieber herr minister
spar meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ihr verbringt man vielen dank
dass sie noch mal darauf hingewiesen
haben dass tatsächlich die
intensivmedizin ja tatsächlich der
einzige schutz den sie hat ist
tatsächlich draußen dieses
infektionsgeschehen herunterzufahren
dass unsere einzige chance und wir sind
leider wird es gerade jetzt so ein
bisschen eine andere situation ich darf
hier bedanken dass wir hier als
intensivmediziner eingeladen worden sind
das ist für uns ganz wichtig dass wir
eine stimme bekommen wir stehen halt mit
den intensiv pflegekräften und dem
ärzten personal am ende dieses
krankheitsverlaufes einer immer wieder
auch schwer verlaufen kogit 19
erkrankung und kämpfen wirklich mit
großem durchhaltevermögen expertise
professionalität und vor allem herzblut
kann ich ihnen sagen gegen den virus und
den schaden den
dieser virus bei den patienten halt
verursacht dennoch werden wir jetzt alle
von diesen steigenden exponent zeit
bestellen der infektionszahlen zunehmend
in bedrängnis gebracht
am ersten zehn das noch mal in
erinnerung zu bringen wurden auf den
intensivstationen 362 cupid 19 patienten
behandelt einen monat später haben wir
gerade gehört 2243 mit 19 prozent das
ist eine steigerung um mehr als das
sechsfache
die verdopplung zeit auch auf der
intensivstation liegt aktuell bei 10
tagen
und diese wird sich angesichts der
exponentiellen zunahme der intensiv
lichenroth 19 patienten in den nächsten
tagen noch verkürzen also wir werden in
den nächsten tagen eine zunahme zu
beobachten haben und begleitet wird
nämlich diese zunahme von einer deutlich
steigenden anzahl von coop 19 patienten
auf der normalstation deutscher
krankenhäuser
also es ist wirklich deutlich spürbar im
vergleich zu april und märz dass wir
deutlich mehr normalstation er gewinnt
19 patienten und zwar auch exponentiell
mehr und bis zu einem drittel dieser
normalstation and patient die werden
nämlich dann auch im fall laufintensiv
wichtig ich möchte also nochmals betonen
dass die entscheidung der
bundesregierung und der mps in der
vergangenen woche zum patienten lockt
tron aus unserer sicht vollumfänglich
richtig gewesen ist denn eines muss doch
klar sein bei einem ungebremsten
weiteren anstieg der infektionszahlen
wurde die intensiv medizin definitiv
definitiv in deutschland in kürzester
zeit an die grenze kommen mit sicherlich
dramatischen folgen
unser kernproblem ist also aktuell ganz
ehrlich nicht die verfügbarkeit
letztlich an intensivbetten
beatmungsgeräten dialyse gerät sondern
der seit jahren bekannte mangel an
fachpersonal und die korona pandemie
verstärkt dieses problem wie ein
brennglas die außerordentlich hohen
infektionszahlen in der bevölkerung
treffen auch meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren nachweislich das
pflegepersonal und ärztliche
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter und
deren infektionen und erkrankungen sowie
risiko kontakte schwächen uns jetzt in
der situation jetzt zusätzlich sie
fallen aus und stehen uns im alltag
nicht mehr zur verfügung mit anderen
worten
tatsächlich ist das nadelöhr versorgung
der kommenden wochen die ausreichende
verfügbarkeit von fachpersonal auf den
intensivstationen oder sehr direkt bei
der lösung es gibt natürlich lösung und
ich bin froh minister lasse sich schon
angesprochen haben
wie auch schon im frühjahr sollten die
krankenhäuser jetzt aus unserer sicht
schnellstmöglich aus dem regelbetrieb
dort aussteigen wo eine hohe
infektionsgefahr mick und jetzt schon
eine einschränkung der bettenkapazität
und ein personalmangel bestehen das
heißt aus ärztlicher sicht vertretbare
ausgesuchte eingriffe müssen abgesetzt
und verschoben werden um so personal
ressourcen bereitzustellen und das
dadurch freigesetzte an es sieht
pflegepersonal und an es wissen können
eine ausreichend große hilfe und
unterstützung in den kernbereichen der
intensivmedizin bieten die damit
verbundenen einnahmeausfälle der
krankenhäuser und das haben sie auch
schon angedeutet sollten bezüglich
unbürokratisch und schnell kompensiert
werden dass bisher aktuell gesetzlich
verankerte konzept die finanziellen
kompensation im weiteren verlauf mit den
krankenkassen zu verhandeln ist aus
sicht der krankenhäuser unzureichend
biete keine verlässlichkeit und
sicherheit und wird zu
liquiditätsengpässen führen
deshalb bitten wir die politik auch ganz
dringend wir wissen dass wir gehört
werden dafür sind wir sehr dankbar um
ein rasches handeln aussetzen des
regelbetriebs und schrittweise an die
regionalen bedürfnisse angepasste
umstellung auf einen notfall betrieb und
hier bedarf es der verordnung durch die
länder sicherstellung der dadurch
entstehenden finanziellen verluste durch
die schon einmal eingesetzte freihalten
pauschale allerdings ein solches konzept
sollte sicherlich sehr differenziert auf
die teilnahme und leistungen der
einzelnen behandlungszentren im rahmen
der korona pandemie angepasst werden
also keine gießkanne meine damen und
herren alles zum ziel damit den druck
von der intensivstation zunehmend
zusätzliches personal aber auch andere
strukturen zu entlassungen dieser
kritischen situation bereitzustellen und
die versorgung kritisch kranker
patienten mit und ohne cupid 19
sicherzustellen
viele der mitarbeiter in den
krankenhäusern den aufnahmen station
normalstation und den intensivstationen
arbeiten wirklich das glauben sie mir
jetzt schon am rande der
belastungsfähigkeit eine gerade von uns
durchgeführte befragung die wir heute im
deutschen
das blatt veröffentlichte zeigt das von
knapp 1100 befragten mit arbeiten im
krankenhaus 97 prozent nicht glauben
dass ausreichend intensiv pflegekräfte
zur verfügung stehen
zudem wir fürchten 93 prozent eine
verschlechterung der arbeitsbedingungen
auf den intensivstationen in den
kommenden monaten aber es besteht ein
definitiv ungebremster wille und eine
extrem hohe motivation gemeinsam diese
krise zu meistern und damit den weg aus
dieser corona pandemie zurück in die
normalität zu finden
dann haben wir noch die perspektive
vielen herzlichen dank meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ich möchte
beginnen mit einem zitat was sie
möglicherweise alle kennen die panini
bewältigung ist eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
entscheidend ist dass sich alle daran
beteiligen ich bin dem
robert-koch-institut sehr dankbar dass
das die headline ist auf der ersten
seite des robert-koch-institutes zu
corona und es schreibt beschreibt das
was die vorreden und vorredner schon
gesagt haben und ich bin auch hier nicht
nur als vertreter von vielen laboren
sondern auch als arzt denn ich bin als
arzt in diesem system tätig und als
bürger und ich bringe mit von vielen
zehntausend mitarbeiter und mitarbeiter
in länder wo in den laboren einerseits
dank dafür dass so viel wertschätzung da
ist für die arbeit der minister hat
freunden gesagt andere politik und
politiker sagen dass auch viele ärzte
näher zu sagen dass draußen und das
freut uns sehr und ich bin genauso hier
mit der bitte all dieser mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiter jetzt fast das testen angeht
auch auf die bremse zu treten um im bild
der berliner ampel zu bleiben wir haben
die rote ampel eigentlich überfahren
unsere tests zahlen übersteigen jetzt
die test kapazitäten und es ist wichtig
und ich bin auch hier herrn schade dem
robert-koch-institut sehr sehr dankbar
dass die kriterien für die testungen so
wie sie im frühjahr waren angepasst
werden an die notwendigkeiten die herbst
und winter mit uns bringen mit uns
bringen
wir möchten alle dass weniger menschen
krank werden an coop 19 wir möchten vor
allen dingen dass weniger schwere
verläufe da sind wir möchten
insbesondere das intensivstation nicht
belegt sind und wir möchten nicht dass
menschen sterben und des diagnostizieren
ist dabei ein wichtiger baustein testen
im labor ist ein wichtiger bestandteil
um infizierte zu erkennen
kontaktperson zu finden und insbesondere
auch den eintrag in risikogruppen ob das
krankenhaus alten ein pflegeheim
ambulant oder stationär ist um das zu
verhindern
dh es ist auch wichtig sich in dem sinne
wie das robert-koch-institut jetzt die
nationale strategie die unser basis ist
seit mai schon und orient unser
orientierungspunkt ist dass die wir die
hier nochmal fokussiert wird und wir uns
daran erinnern was es vordringlich um
durch testen was ja mittel zum zweck ist
diese erkrankung zu begleiten was durch
test notwendig ist damit wir alle
kranken erkennen und deren
kontaktpersonen schnell identifizieren
können
ich möchte gar nicht so sehr auf die
testmethoden eingehen ich denke die ein
oder andere frage
oder wird dazu auftauchen ich danke auch
frau bringt man sehr dass ich noch
einmal gesagt hat man musste mich ja
mechaniker nicht erklären wo der motor
im auto ist und deswegen braucht es dem
labor auch keine erklärung zu geben wie
pcr funktioniert das ist die referenz
methode die es richtig um eindeutig
erkrankungen zu finden und wir freuen
uns und wir finden es wichtig dass wir
jetzt mit den anti gen tests die neue da
sind die werden wir jetzt intensiv
untersuchen dass wir zusätzliche
bausteine haben
ich finde auch das bild von der
löchrigen käse scheibe sehr gut wird
wissen um die einschränkung der antigen
tester wir sind dennoch wichtig und
richtig um in dieser situation einen
guten beitrag leisten zu können und
deswegen ist es auch richtig gewesen
dass im rahmen der korona test
verordnung diesem diagnostischen mittel
ein raum geschaffen worden ist wir sind
im moment gerade dabei zum beispiel in
den laboratorien die labor bezogenen
antigen test uns anzuschauen damit wir
zusätzlich zu den antigenen vor ort es
in den arztpraxen hier einen guten
freitag leisten werden können
aus unserer debatte ist es wichtig jetzt
zu handeln
zusammen zu handeln das geht nur
interdisziplinär die mikrobiologin
mikrobiologen die labor wo ärzte allein
können das nicht wir sind darauf
angewiesen dass erstens die bevölkerung
mit macht nicht nur durch einhalten der
aha plus app nutzen plus lüften regel
sondern auch um sich gedanken zu machen
wann kann ich im sinne der der
testmöglichkeit mann ist es gut für mich
und es zu haben muss sich alle drei
wochen zum test gehen und so bekam ich
auch guten rat gute hilfe und gute
informationen
für testen beraten zu können nur
gemeinsam können wir das machen indem
die ärztinnen und ärzte diese nationale
tech strategie die jetzt wieder
fokussiert ist die bekannte es sozusagen
verinnerlichen und anwenden und wir
werden in den labor und immer dafür
sorgen können dass ist eigentlich eine
positive botschaft zum schluss die auch
wichtig ist dass alle menschen den test
brauchen weil es erforderlich ist aus
medizinischen gründen zur abklärung
bestimmter fragen die werden auch immer
einen solchen test auch eine pc
untersuchung bekommen können
denn bei einer kapazität von 1,4
millionen tests das ist weitaus mehr als
wir für viele andere pc untersuchungen
vieler anderer erreger in deutschland
überhaupt zur verfügung haben
bei 1,4 millionen testmöglichkeiten
werden wir das sicherlich
bewerkstelligen können dass alle die aus
medizinischen diagnostischen gründen
einen solchen test benötigen dass die
dann auch bekommen wesentlich ist dass
wir die leistungsfähigkeit die
motivation das engagement der
mitarbeiter mitarbeiter in den laboren
die sich wirklich sehr sehr engagieren
diese aber durch sehen dass wir die
erhalten dass wir die überlastung
vermeiden und jetzt hier wie in anderen
bereichen auch ein stückchen die bremse
betätigen und das testen auf das maß
zurückführen das sinnvoll und richtig
ist
ich habe da schon angesprochen die
nationale strategie und damit wären wir
gut vorankommen und dann auch diesen
herz diesen winter meistern indem neben
coop 19
auch influenza kommt und die meisten von
ihnen wären das wissen im labor wird
nicht nur kurz 19 untersucht sondern
alle anderen erkrankungen die mit labor
diagnostizierte monitors in der therapie
überwacht werden sind dort verortet und
deswegen ist auch wichtig dass wir das
im blick behalten herzlichen dank danke
dafür dann kommen wir zu ihren fragen
ich habe schon jede menge wortmeldung
gesehen hier im saal hat auch fragen der
kollegen die uns online welche
zugestellt haben ich werde es versuchen
zu mischen wenn möglich nach aspekten zu
ordnen
vorgeschaltet noch ein dankeschön dafür
dass sie sich alle an die winter halten
hier im saal auch eine maske zu tragen
wenn es ihnen
es ist auch gerne beim sprechen mal so
beim frage stellen und eine bitte wenn
sie eine frage stellen stellen sie sich
vielleicht kurz vor und sagen dazu an
wen sich die frage richtet und ich
beginne mit einer frage online vom
kollegen wegener von dpa der sie herr
sparen persönlich fragt haben sie aus
ihrer persönlichen erfahrung mit dem
virus etwas für ihre arbeit gelernt hat
dass die professionelle sich noch einmal
beeinflusst na klar ist dass immer was
anderes etwas zehn monate lang zu
besprechen
und doch politisch und konkret durch tun
damit umzugehen oder es selbst zu haben
die diagnose zu bekommen und das was im
übrigen isolation bedeutet und
quarantäne in der sich gerade
hunderttausende muss man sich übrigens
mal vergegenwärtigen in deutschland
aktuell sind hunderttausende menschen in
isolation weil positiv getestet oder in
quarantäne weil kontaktperson und das
ist schon was zehn oder 14 tage
quarantäne dann tatsächlich zu hause zu
bleiben das ist eine enorme
einschränkung die wirkliche sorge wie
der verlauf ist beschäftigt viele die
infiziert sind und insofern ist das
tatsächlich etwas wo ich noch mal eher
demütig und dankbar bin das ist so gut
gelaufen ist aber vor allem auch dass
ich mich zu jedem zeitpunkt wie alle
anderen deutschen auch auf einen
gesundheitswesen verlassen kann vom
gesundheitsamt angefangen bis zu den
ärztinnen und ärzten einen anderen gast
begleiten das jeden tag sein bestes gibt
ich finde das ist das was in der
situation ein stück auch vor
dann gibt und zuversicht und das spüren
hoffentlich viele tausende und millionen
deutsche jeden tag dann machen wir im
saal weiter mit fragen bei den kollegen
von philipp sandmann von rtl und n tv
das wild ganz gut gefallen was frau
bringt man verwendet hat mit dem
mechaniker
den man ja auch nicht sagt immer die
motor repariert wenn man jetzt mal in
dem bild bleibt dann sind die tests
sicherlich ein teil des motors diese
pandemie zu bewältigen die krone app
mindestens mal der warnblinker braucht
es in dieser krise möglicherweise eine
verpflichtende corona app um die
kontakte nach verfolgung nach
lückenloser zu machen und wo liegen da
die politischen hürden und müsste man
den datenschutz da vielleicht mal hinten
anstellen und die zweite frage an herrn
sparen auch wenn sie erlauben wurde auch
viel besprochen in essen gibt es so eine
art portal wo man fotos hochladen kann
oder informationen über menschen die
sich nicht an die krone regeln gehalten
haben sollte man so etwas überall
einführen oder ist das schlichtweg die
und denunziantentum und sollte man sich
davon lieber verschieben
danke zuerst einmal was die korona waren
angeht haben wir uns ja sehr bewusst
auch in einer gesellschaftlich
politischen debatte für den freiwilligen
ansatz entschieden
ich wusste übrigens auch lebenspraktisch
nicht wie ein anderer ansatz ohne mit
sehr stark kontrollieren den mechanismen
die man sich eigentlich nicht wünschen
kann denn funktionieren soll
wir haben jetzt 21,6 millionen
bürgerinnen und bürger in deutschland
die die app heruntergeladen haben das
ist schon ein sehr hoher anteil
wir werden jeden tag darum dass es noch
mehr werden wir haben übrigens
mittlerweile über zwei millionen tests
die über die app im testergebnis auch
mitgeteilt worden sind also auch der
teil der am anfang gar nicht so sehr im
fokus war macht ja ein unterschied weil
das ergebnis schneller da ist wir sehen
immer mehr nutzerinnen und nutzer die
auch ihr positives testergebnis teilen
und da sind dinge wo wir besser werden
wollen dass zum beispiel immer dem
nichts seinen testergebnis teilt dass es
im zweifel noch meine erinnerungen gibt
daran dass wir da ein stück mehr
verbindlichkeit ohne verpflichtend zu
sein
hineinbringen auch in den
rückkopplungsschleife dass auf jeden
fall aber ich glaube nicht dass eine
verpflichtende einsatz oder ansatz am
ende akzeptanz erhöht und eine etwas wie
die korona waren erlebt hat auch sehr
davon dass es immer hohe akzeptanz gibt
das gleiche gilt für maßnahmen
und ihr einhalten und umsetzen wir
müssen alle gemeinsam jahr zusammen im
alltag diese balance finden und das
kennen wir übrigens sehr aus anderen
lebensbereichen auch wir haben hier
viele regeln miteinander keiner lebt für
sich allein
es gibt die situation wo man den anderen
darauf hinweist dass selbst sich
vielleicht gerade nicht an eine regel
hält ob es die rote ampel ist über die
fußgängerampel oder was weiß ich in
welcher lebenssituation das ist oder
eben möglicherweise auf eine maske trägt
oder nicht
und ich finde das sollten diejenigen die
in der situation miteinander sind
erstens miteinander ausmachen und
zweitens konkrete kontrollen durch
behörden ist geben wie es sie in bei
anderen regeln auch gibt ich glaube
nicht dass es auf dauer die gesellschaft
gut tut wenn über soziale medien man
sich gegenseitig denunziert oder über
das internet dass das ist vielleicht der
teil der dann am ende auch nicht
zusammenhalt befördert sondern eher das
gegenteil
die nächste frage die nächste frage
die regeln im moment die regeln hier
sind sich erneut dass sie gern noch mal
entweder entscheidet man sich für das
modell frage und nachfrage oder man
stellt zwei dass in ihrem fall drei auf
einmal dann nehme ich sie gern hinten
noch mal auf die liste und die nächste
frage hat die kollegin dahinter ja
vielen dank mein name ist lisa braun
presseagentur gesundheit
ich habe eine frage an den minister zum
zweiten mal ist ja flecken zu kaufen
unser aller oberstes ziel und sie sind
ja nicht nur der minister von kogit 19
patienten sondern es gibt ja noch eine
ganze menge anderer patienten
was wissen sie konkret über die
kollateralschäden dieser strategie und
ja sie haben jetzt auch aus der
isolation sicherlich verfolgt was die
ärztefunktionäre in der zeit von sich
gegeben haben vielleicht können sie da
noch auch noch mal kurz was zu sagen zum
thema war es getragen
bundesärztekammer-präsident
beispielsweise oder der vorstoß von
herrn doktor gassen neulich dankeschön
zum ersten ja wir sind wieder bei fremde
körper die kurve
das exponentielle wachstum
runterzubringen aber wir sind eben auch
differenzierter ansatz also mir ist das
sehr sehr wichtig wir sind in einer
anderen situation als im frühjahr
wir wissen erst ins meer
und wir können zweitens und wollen auch
21 differenzierter vorgehen eine sehr
bewusste entscheidung gewesen kitas und
schulen offen zu lassen im regelbetrieb
unter pandemie bedingung eine sehr
bewusste entscheidung gewesen handel und
wirtschaft so weit es geht offen zu
lassen um arbeitsplätze zu sichern und
dann ist es eben umgekehrt auch eine
bewusste entscheidung gewesen und
anderen bereichen umso stärker die
kontakte einzuschränken also das ist ja
schon mal auch aus den erkenntnissen der
letzten monate ein wichtiger ein
wichtiger unterschied wir haben die wahl
wir haben verschiedene
verhaltensempfehlungen die wir auch
anders und zielgerichteter geben können
als das noch im frühjahr der fall
gewesen ist ich will aber auch sagen
weil ich die tage angolas das kann doch
jetzt nicht plötzlich im november
wissen sie ich kann mich erinnern
übrigens auch hier sitzen dass wir schon
im august und september darauf
hingewiesen haben dass feiern
insbesondere feiern in größeren
zusammenhängen risiken mit sich bringt
das ist jetzt nicht plötzlich gewesen
die erkenntnis und dann auch die
maßnahme dass die veranstaltungs größe
und die möglichkeit des geselligen
miteinander science weil eben dieses
virus da der spielverderber ist dass das
ein bereich ist der mit als erstes in
den focus kommt das war immer auch
bestandteil unserer ansätze und dessen
was wir gesagt und dann jetzt eben auch
getan haben was die frage von
patientinnen und patienten angeht die
nicht an coop 19 erkrankt sind geht es
natürlich darum und auch da wissen wir
heute mehr kann das gesundheitswesen
auch besser damit umgehen als im
frühjahr
übrigens was ganz wichtig ist weil wir
gerade über kliniken sprachen neun von
zehn cupid 19 patienten in deutschland
werden ambulant behandelt es auch mal
wichtig zu sehen dass ist der erste
schutzwall
und das ist eben besser gelingt zu
trennen
diejenigen die kurve 19 infiziert sind
oder ein verdachtsfall sind von der
versorgung und behandlung aller anderen
patientinnen und patienten die chronisch
krank sind oder akut krank sind das ist
in den kliniken so dass es in den
arztpraxen so dass es in anderen
bereichen des gesundheitswesens weil das
ist natürlich sehr sehr wichtig dass
auch die anderen erkrankungen und die
patientinnen und patienten behandelt
werden
und nach allem was wir sehen gibt es
jetzt jedenfalls aus den ersten
auswertungen studien die ich gesehen
habe aus abrechnungsdaten und andere
mehr noch keine guten validen
erkenntnisse das werden wir
wahrscheinlich erst der zeitversetzt
sehen ob und welche folgeschäden es auch
gibt möglicherweise weil früherkennungs
oder vorsorgeuntersuchungen frühjahr
insbesondere vielleicht verschoben
worden sind nicht stattgefunden haben
das können wir jetzt noch nicht sagen
aber ich kann ihnen sagen da habe ich
als bundesminister für gesundheit auch
ein hohes interesse dass wir das
natürlich sehr genau verfolgen was da
passiert und was nicht passiert und
deswegen letzter punkt war auch der
hinweis von herr janssen so wichtig wir
reden wenn dann über operationen die aus
merzien medizinisch vertretbaren gründen
auch verschiebbar sind natürlich wäre es
im zweifel immer besser auch aus sicht
des patienten wenn sie stattfinden
würden wie geplant aber bei denen es
eben auch medizinisch vertretbar ist sie
zu verschieben das finde ich sehr
wichtig dann vielleicht ein hinweis an
herrn buchstein hat er uns zuhört die
frage betrachte ich damit als
beantwortet wenn ich gern noch mal
melden und dann machen wir weiter im
saal ob der von uns aus gesehen linken
seite ja immer quält wisch vom
onlinemagazin mit watch und freier
journalist
ich wollte fragen ob es uns jetzt nicht
sehr auf die füße fällt dass wir immer
noch zu wenig wissen über die
ausbreitung und die folgen der
erkrankung zum beispiel gibt es bislang
also meines wissens nach keine
systematischen studien zu den
langzeitschäden die manche patienten
haben und zur frage wie auch das der
fall ist und auch zur ausbreitung müssen
wir also wenig also nur für einen
bruchteil der patienten oder der
infektion so ein bisschen der ja wo sie
sich anstecken von merkel hat er
mehrfach von 75 prozent gesprochen von
denen wir es nicht wissen
aber das umfasst auch gar nicht die
dunkelziffer und es ist doch eigentlich
nur ein paar prozent der fälle müssen
also der inflation verwiesen dass in
bestimmten umfeld passiert
warum wissen wir nicht mehr und warum
gibt es nicht schon viel länger
studieren und ergebnisse dazu ein wenig
tten sie die frage an herrn spahn gerne
also zum ersten es gibt studien die
natürlich aber eine langzeitstudie wie
der name schon sagt kann halt nach drei
oder sechs monaten noch keine validen
ergebnisse natürlich abschließend
bringen aber es gibt langzeitstudien
übrigens weil das gab es ja auch eine
nachvollziehbare debatte vor einigen
monaten über die frage von obduktionen
wir fördern auch obduktion register und
auch dort aus diesem bereich
erkenntnisse zu gewinnen natürlich gibt
es die aber gerade alles was
langzeitbetrachtung angeht braucht dann
auch eine gewisse zeit bis es
entsprechende erkenntnisse geben kann
was die frage des ansteckung sword es
angeht ich kann der ja nur am ende auch
festgehalten werden wenn der oder
diejenige tatsächlich das zuordnen kann
wo sie sich angesteckt hat und natürlich
mit einem steigenden infektionsgeschehen
wird das auch tatsächlich immer
schwieriger und ich kann auch ganz
persönlich sagen ich werde ja schon
öfter gefragt den letzten tage ich
könnte ihnen nicht sagen wo ich mich
angesteckt haben und überall da wo ich
vermutet hatte es hätte passieren können
war es nicht der fall weil alle
betreffenden kontaktperson negativ
getestet wurden dann anschließend ich
könnte wenn sie ich wäre einer von
diesen 75 prozent die nicht sagen können
wo es passiert ist und so geht es glaube
ich vielen der infizierten insbesondere
beim infektionsgeschehen wie wir es im
moment haben auch mit den zahlen wie sie
im moment sind dass das eben nicht
abschließbar gesagt werden kann dass
beim restaurant oder das wird da das war
in der schule sondern es ist passiert
ohne dass man es eben gemerkt hat das
ist ja das tückische an diesem virus wie
frau professor brinkmann gesagt hat dass
im zeitverzug überhaupt erst
möglicherweise die symptome auftreten
man ist schon infektiös ist dadurch auch
unheimlich schwierig ist dann zu wissen
wann und wo es passiert ist das ist mit
eine schwierigkeit die wir in dieser
pandemie haben aber ich bin bei und das
wären wir mit dem öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst ich bin ihr professor
schade und so ergänzen möchte aus ihrer
sicht und noch mal besprechen wie wir da
natürlich noch besser zu noch besseren
daten kommen können aber die können nur
so gut sein wie die bürgerinnen und
bürger sie am ende eben auch konkret
machen können wollte grenzen also lange
zeit heißt tatsächlich wie herr minister
schon gesagt hat
69 12 monate
wer in der medizin in solchen räumen wir
wissen aber schon dass chinesischen
studien ganz am anfang dass wir schon
mit so post viralen syndrom zu tun haben
der schöpfung zu druck fertig
wir schauen sehr genau auf die lungen
drauf das muss man ganz klar sagen ob da
ein langsamer lauf probleme sich
entwickeln zum beispiel diese kleine
micro thromben die ja das krankheitsbild
ja auch prägen und auch neurologische
spätfolgen sind da in der beobachtung
und wir wissen auch dass ein relativ
hoher prozentsatz von patienten auch ein
herz mit beteilung hat das wissen wir
jetzt nach 23 monaten wir wissen aber
nicht was das für eine auswirkung in
zwölf monaten haben würden diese fragen
werden wir mit hundertprozentiger
gewissheit in einem jahr genau hier
wieder weiter besprechen können dann
wären wir nicht wirklich gute daten an
das sind alle wissenschaftler aus allen
fachgebieten jetzt dran das zu
untersuchen
jetzt mal eine frage dazu die auch
zumindest den themenkreis daten berührt
julia noll vom handelsblatt fragt herrn
spahn und herrn schade
eine aktuelle us analyse zeigt dass
aufgekommene hotspots durch analyse der
daten von smart watches & aktivitäts
treckern vorausgesagt werden können
inwieweit werden in der pandemie analyse
künftig vermehrt die erkenntnisse aus
der korona daten spende app einbezogen
um regionaler und früher reagieren zu
können
ja also das ist genau die idee die
dahinter steckt
bei der korona daten spende act geht es
letztendlich darum im grunde
fieberkurven zu messen auf bevölkerungs
ebene indem man eben die impuls auf der
einen seite greift über diese devices
sie so zum beispiel die lodges und auf
der anderen seite eben den den
bewegungsradius oder dem
bewegungsaktivität und wenn man hohen
puls hat bei wenig bewegung dann spricht
das für fiber in der masse jedenfalls
statistisch gesehen und wir wissen im
moment dass das ganz gut korreliert mit
den fallzahlen und was die regionale
auflösung angeht da muss man natürlich
immer schauen wir haben etwas über
500.000 mit spendende in diesem projekt
das funktioniert auf bundesebene sehr
gut dass man dort sagen kann
dass hier eine sage ich mal fieber
aktivität ist die dann auch in den
fallzahlen zu sehen ist
da werden wir demnächst sicherlich auch
auf der ebene ganz ganz vorsichtig
prognosen wagen können im moment sind
wir dann noch in der validierungs phase
wenn man das jetzt herunter brechen will
auf sehr enge räumliche umschriebene
gebiete dann wird es natürlich immer
schwieriger und in der studie kann man
das gut machen dann gibt man eben ein
die in einer region leben so ein device
und dann kann man das abgreifen
aber wenn man das freiwillig und auch
bevölkerungs ebene macht dann kann man
auch da nur appellieren diese studie die
wir haben ist schon sehr groß aber je
mehr mitmachen umso feiner auflösend
wird man diese informationen dann auch
haben können
im moment funktioniert das auf
bundesebene ganz gut auf bundeslandebene
einigermaßen und je weniger das dann
eben von der geographischen abdeckung
wird desto schwieriger sei weiter bei
herrn linke eine frage an herrn sparen
sie haben ja die forderung von deinen
ganzen gehört was die kliniken angeht
und dass die das freiheiten von betten
nun für komapatienten ich hätte ganz
gerne von ihnen gewusst wie schnell sie
dabei vorgehen wollen soll die
kompensation vom bund kommen denn das
ist ja die forderung wenn ich es richtig
verstanden habe von den ärzten und eine
frage an herrn schade das ist viel von
exponentiellen wachstum die rede gewesen
gibt es das im moment noch oder sehen
sie schon eine leichte trendwende jetzt
nur bei den neuinfektionen nicht bei
allen anderen faktoren also zum ersten
wir haben heute eine gesetzliche
regelung die für das letzte quartal
dieses jahres eine defizit abdeckung
vorsieht in einfachen worten ein haus
kann sich sicher sein mindestens das
finanziell auch aus krankenkassen
einnahmen zu haben was es letztes jahr
im vierten quartal hatte darunter fällt
niemand aber da hat ganz recht das ist
sozusagen eine zeitlich nachgelagert
situation das kann er erst betrachtet
werde im januar februar und eine die
dann eben mit den krankenkassen haus
bezogen verhandelt wird es gibt
liquiditäts themen für einige häuser
natürlich in dem moment wo operationen
verschoben werden die korona bedingten
mehrausgaben für schutzausrüstungen sind
heute auch schon gesetzlich
geld das die übernommen werden bei der
debatte um die frei halte pauschale ich
weiß auch gar nicht ob der begriff
freihalten pauschales abschließend gut
trifft weil wir ja vor allem sehen dass
die bett nehmen nicht mehr frei sind
sondern sich füllen jedenfalls haben wir
den corona beirat gebeten
es gibt den nach gesetz weil der
vorgesehen auskosten trägern also
krankenkassen krankenhaus vertretern
experten darüber hinaus wies
krankenhausbereich und kolleginnen und
kollegen aus dem ministerium
der hat uns während der ersten phase der
pandemie bis in den september hinein
einmütig übrigens jeweils kostenträger
und krankenhäuser sehr konkrete
vorschläge gemacht wie mit der situation
in den krankenhäusern gut abbilden
können gesetzgeberisch genau das gleiche
wieder machen wir haben gebeten anfangen
soll sie mal eben rechnen anfang
nächster woche genau von dato mehr
anfang nächster woche das wird jetzt
vorbereitet dass die zusammenkommen und
uns empfehle umgeben und wir sind
grundsätzlich bereit diese empfehlung
daneben auch umzusetzen ich natürlich
eine konkreten konkreten vorschlag aber
meine erfahrung ist durch die
zusammensetzung des gremiums sind das in
aller regel sehr gut handelbare
vorschläge
das hieße aber natürlich auch das sei
dazu gesagt dass das was wir hatten das
nämlich aus dem bundeshaushalt eine
entsprechende mit finanzierung erfolgt
auch hier notwendig ist alleine aus
krankenkassen mitteln ist dass in der
aktuellen finanzlage nicht möglich ja
wir hatten in den letzten vier wochen
etwa einen sogenannten er wert vor der
so etwa bei 1,314 manchmal auch etwas
darüber lag das bedeutet exponentielles
wachstum und solange der wert über 1 ist
haben wir exponentielles wachstum
gestern war aber 1,17 und glauben etwa
das kann man sich ungefähr so vorstellen
wie zins wachstum also das ist ein bild
von der kollegin prise man dass ich dann
einfach hier nochmal
zitieren darf er 1,1 oder ein eher wert
von 1,1 das entspricht einem zinssatz
von 10 prozent und jeder kann sich
ausrechnen zehn prozent wenn man die
zinsen kriegt das wird immer mehr die
zinsen werden immer mehr und das ist
exponentiell so lange bis im grunde
dieser wert auf null ist also alle jeder
erbert über 1 ist exponentiell wir sehen
zwar in den letzten tagen einen gewissen
rückgang dieses erwerbs also die kurve
wird vermutlich etwas flacher im moment
das muss man noch sehr vorsichtig
betrachten weil einige tage da noch
keine feste aussage machen können ob das
tatsächlich eine trendwende ist das ist
erst mal nur eine beobachtung aber bis
gestern und der wert für heute der steht
noch nicht fest er wird heute abend im
lagebericht stehen bis gestern hatten
wir exponentielles wachstum vita titel
von der bild mit zwei fragen einer an
herrn sparen und einer ins ak ihn zuerst
ihren ca
die haben jetzt mehrfach zahlen gemeldet
die sie dann korrigieren mussten vorher
woche mittwoch glaube ich hatten wir die
vom vortrag gehabt gab es andere zahlen
woran liegt das liegt das am yakari oder
liegt es an den gesundheitsämtern die
beim melden nicht mehr hinterherkommen
und was sind dann die zahlen überhaupt
wert also wenn jetzt wieder wenn sich
gesundheitsämter und zum beispiel auch
die getesteten gar nicht mehr erreichen
wenn leute gar nicht mehr getestet
werden sondern direkt in die quarantäne
oder isolation sollen was sind dann die
zahlen doch wert die jeden tag dem
verkündet werden und an herrn spahn
sie haben tolle erfahrung gemacht mit
ihm wird gesundheitsamt besonders in den
ballungsräumen aber haben
hunderttausende gerade würde ich andere
erfahrungen
die telefonieren sie von pontius zu
pilatus sie erreichten das
gesundheitsamt nicht in werden zum
beispiel ist es in berlin so von sieben
gesundheitsämtern sechs verschiedene
regeln für die quarantäne oder
isolierung genannt die leute sollen sich
selbst in die quarantäne begeben
gekommen aber vom gesundheitsamt keine
bescheinigung der den arbeitgeber
brauchen sie rufen hausärzte an werden
von denen aber nicht telefonisch krank
geschrieben weil sie sagen dass sie in
kantinen müssen dafür schreiben die
ärzte nicht krank was sagen sie diesen
menschen das klingt alles wirklich toll
was wir jetzt hören aber die leute
machen gerade in den ballungsräumen
komplett andere erfahrung dort
also ich sage einmal mit letzterem an
das ist ja genau der grund aus dem wir
die maßnahmen ergreifen der täter zwei
leben wir in einer zunehmenden zahl von
gesundheitsämtern wären die situation
kommen dass kontaktpersonen
nachverfolgung nicht mehr so gelingt die
das idealerweise der fall ist und wie
das sein muss um die dynamik zu brechen
und immer wieder aufs neue
infektionsketten und vor allem ihr auch
und da sind wir bei der debatte zu
clustern oder superstar
wenn man die namen begriffe dann kommen
eben ereignisse damit zu verunmöglichen
in der rückwärtsbewegung in der
aufarbeitung aber vor allem auch nach
vorne wo es dann zu besonders vielen
ansteckung kommt und uns ist sehr
bewusst dass eine zunehmende zahl von
gesundheitsämtern eben nicht mehr
hinterherkommt das ist ja das was sie
beschreiben und das ist ja einer der
gründe neben der entwicklung auf der
intensivstation neben der entwicklung in
behandlungsbedarf warum wir im november
zu diesen maßnahmen greifen ich kann
auch sagen das ist jetzt aber am ende
januar anekdotische imperia aus
persönlichem erleben und berichten von
anderen dass es im moment keine da bin
ich bei ihnen ausreichende
einheitlichkeit in der anwendung von
charakteren und test regeln gibt das ist
auch sehr unterschiedlichen situationen
jeweils geschuldet und deswegen ist das
aus meiner sicht einer der hauptpunkte
die die ich mich auch persönlich kümmern
möchte zusammen mit den kolleginnen und
kollegen aus dem öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst aus dem
robert-koch-institut aus dem alltag
heraus dass wir aus dem november heraus
dass die frage von counter quarantäne
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung die
debatte zu den clustern miteinander das
nochmal weiter entwickeln einfach mit
den erfahrungen aus den letzten wochen
ist funktioniert im moment nicht überall
so wie es soll
und das ist genau der grund mit warum
wir zu den maßnahmen greifen neben der
frage der zahlen zu den herrn professor
scheine was sagt eines was mich auch
politisch beschäftigt ist dass wir neben
der melde- fragen zunehmend cyber
angriff
erleben im übrigen auch aufs
robert-koch-institut und auf die
institutionen in dem bereich das ist
einer der gründe übrigens auch bei den
kliniken ein zunehmendes thema warum der
auch stärker in cyber sicherheit im
gesundheitswesen investieren und
investieren müssen
aber das ist eben eines der punkte die
wir auch beim robert-koch-institut
leider wie auch bei uns übrigens im
ministerium gelegentlich feststellen
müssen diskrepanzen in den fallzahlen
zwischen den verschiedenen ebenen das
ist die frage die ich im grunde daraus
gehört habe dass einmal das ist ja schon
oft gesprochen worden
der sogenannte melde verzug die
gesundheitsämter und die landkreise die
wissen ihre zahlen einfach früher als
wir sie bei uns ankommen je nach land
die haben da unterschiedliche schemata
nach denen das bearbeiten das kann
teilweise am selben abend ankommen in
einigen ländern teilweise aber auch erst
nach zwei oder auch drei tagen das ist
ein punkt dieser diskrepanzen zeitmäßig
werden wir so nur dann ändern können
wenn alle länder sich hier auf eine
einheitliche einheitliches vorgehen
einigen
gleichzeitig gibt es auch noch den
umstand dass es eben einfach fehler bei
der eingabe gibt also es ist die
möglichkeit dass zum beispiel fälle
doppelt erfasst werden dann haben wir
die eine zeit doppelt in der statistik
bis das gesundheitsamt die wieder
korrigiert und herausholt das
gesundheitsamt weiß aber natürlich schon
vorher bevor sie das im system
korrigiert dass sich eine doublette
vorliegen hat das können auch manchmal
50 tabletten auf einmal sein denn was
schief gelaufen ist und kommuniziert
dass dann oftmals schon das ist zum
beispiel anfang dieser woche der fall
gewesen warum es unterschiedliche zahlen
gehabt zwischen einem landkreis und dem
robert koch institut das korrigiert sich
dann aber wieder
also diese korrektur das nachziehen der
korrektur das sorgt eben dafür dass
diese ferne sich eben auch nachträglich
immer noch wieder minimal verändern
können sind aber natürlich bei 15.000
fehlen wenn er mal 50 korrigiert werden
sagte es an der grundaussage erstmal
nichts aus was passiert wenn die tritt
es kapazitäten komplett praktisch am
anschlag sind dann würden wir natürlich
irgendwann immer die dunkelziffer wird
immer größer werden das würden wir dann
an stagnierenden fallzahlen im grund
sehen das ist im moment noch nicht der
fall dafür erfassen wir letztendlich
diese sogenannte positiven rate die ist
gestiegen von unter einem prozent im
august auf jetzt 5,6 prozent das ist
immer noch eine ganz gute quote also nur
etwa und also nicht mal jeder zehnte
durchgeführte test ist positiv insgesamt
gesehen wenn diese quote sehr viel
steigt dann wird natürlich auch die
unter erfassung höher
das können wir aber dann abschätzen
durch diese positive rate und für diesen
fall haben wir systeme in vorbereiteten
laufen auch schon das sind so genannte
sentinel systeme die dann auch
bevölkerungs ebene die virusaktivität
messen nicht mehr in jedem einzelfall
sondern die aktivität auf bevölkerungs
ebene angeben und zwar gibt es da zum
beispiel die skripte web das ist eine
webseite kann jeder mitmachen und seine
eigenen symptome an eingeben aber auch
einen test dort zum beispiel anfordern
den machen wir dann ein testkit es gibt
es in arztpraxen das ist die so genannte
ag die dieses sentinel macht wie viele
personen mit respiratorischen
infektionen sind in arztpraxen und wie
viele davon haben kogit also da wird
nicht jeder erfasst sondern nur ein
repräsentativer anteil und letztendlich
gibt es auch auf intensivstationen das
ist der sogenannte ego saar ii system da
können wir eben sehen wie viele von den
fällen mit neumann ihn auf
intensivstationen sind cupid 19 fälle
also für diesen fall ist vorgesorgt wir
können das geschehen dann beurteilen
aber eben repräsentativ auf bevölkerungs
ebene und nicht in jedem einzelfall
ich nehme eine frage dazu das geht auch
um die daten von der von gisela breuer
gesundheitspolitischer
informationsdienst sie fragt auch sehr
schade
trifft es zu dass in die statistik als
kopf 19 verstorbener auch verstorbene
eingehen die beispielsweise an einem
herzinfarkt oder einen einem autounfall
gestorben sind aber positiv auf corona
getestet waren also der muss schon einen
zusammenhang vorliegen also entweder
eben
unmittelbar ursächlich oder eben eine
komplikation bei einem vor erkrankten
patienten autounfall bei einem der wohl
zufällig auch coop mit 19 festgestellt
worden
das würde nicht in die statistik
eingehen da gibt es auch eine
entsprechende ausführliche erläuterung
auf unserer website als faq dann machen
wir im saal weiter bei frau emrich ich
hoffe ich treffe das richtige weg ist es
das richtige
genau da hab ich habe auch eine frage an
sie herr sparen denn wir haben ja jetzt
gelernt wie lange es dauert bis
maßnahmen wirken bis die zahl der
neuinfektionen runtergeht und bis das
haben jetzt gerade hier noch mal gesehen
auch tatsächlich die zahl der
intensivpatienten ich denke alles das im
wochen versucht nun wollen ja die
kanzlerin und die ministerpräsidenten
bereits übernächste woche am montag
die maßnahmen des neuen lok downs
bewerten und sich fragen hatte schon was
gebracht oder nicht können wir ende
november wieder leicht öffnen oder
müssen wir sogar weiter machen wenn man
das hier alles so hört ist es überhaupt
realistisch dass ich bis dahin bei den
zahlen was geändert hat oder müssen wir
uns von der illusion verabschieden dass
das so schnell geht also zuerst einmal
mehr fällt mir übrigens auf in der frage
teil frage von frauen gar nicht
beantwortet hatte nämlich die zu der
aktuellen debatte auch ich fühle mich
jetzt gar nicht in die debatte von
unterschiedlichen wissenschaftlern
ärzten perspektiven das geld zur freien
choralen gesellschaft dazu dass es diese
diskussion gibt gleichwohl müssen auch
die die sagen schaut nicht nur auf die
infektionszahlen sondern schaut auf die
intensiv medizin denke ich in der
aktuellen lage anerkennen dass bei
betrachten der intensivmedizin wir
handlungsbedarf haben und ich finde
einen nur schauen auch intensiv medizin
das ist auch zu spät von professor
brinkmann eine zu recht darauf
hingewiesen was ist das eigentlich für
ein parameter wenn man sagt für uns ist
der entscheidende parameter dann wenn
eigentlich ist zu sehr schief gegangen
ist und menschen zu schwerem schaden
gekommen sind und schwersten verläufen
insofern ist dieser zeitverzug der da
drin ist aus hohen infektionszahlen
werden früher oder später insbesondere
übrigens in einem land dass das
zweitälteste nach japan auf der welt ist
ich find auch manche diskussionen über
die frage von risikogruppen und
das zu schützen in gruppen führt man
vielleicht in einem land das ein
durchschnittsalter von 15 jahren hat wie
nigeria anders als in einem land wie
deutschland das eines der ältesten auf
der welt ist und wo per definitionem
risikogruppe eine ziemlich große damit
auch ist vielleicht auch etwas anders
als ich das gelegentlich in manchen
öffentlichen äußerungen so höher also
dieser zeitverzug ist da und deswegen
wird man jetzt sichern auch sehen dass
hat der ernstes beschrieben dass auf der
intensiv medizin die zahlen weiter
steigen in den nächsten zwei drei wochen
mindestens das ist absehbar aus den
entwicklungen der letzten wochen und den
infektionszahlen ob zum 16 11 und in
welchem umfang sich das zumal man ja
einsehen muss es gab ja eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundesregierung mitte oktober aus der
heraus ja auch schon erste maßnahmen
ergriffen wurden
ob und in welchem umfang das zum 16 11
absehbar sein wird schon das können wir
jetzt nicht abschließend sagen aber das
sind immerhin zwei wochen
das sind etwa drei zyklen wenn man
sozusagen diese vier tages zyklen nimmt
für dieses virus das kann ja doch wieder
als generation zeiten nimmt dann müsste
man eigentlich was sehen können
aber abschließend sagen kann es zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt noch niemand
kurz ein hinweis zwischendurch wir sind
eigentlich in der bundespressekonferenz
bemüht veranstaltung nicht mehr viel
länger als eine stunde dauern zu lassen
auch um ja einfach den lüftungs
austausch sicherzustellen
ich habe jetzt noch zahlreiche
wortmeldungen auf der auf dem zettel
würde aber sagen 14 uhr ist tatsächlich
dann ende der veranstaltungen versuchen
noch so gut wie möglich durch zu kommen
deswegen noch einmal die bitte fassen
sie sich kurz ja jetzt ja ich habe zwei
fragen
dann traf professor brinkmann eine
andere müller verbringt dann wenn ich es
richtig sehe das virus kopiert sich kann
man ihn selbst um sich weiter verbreiten
zu können bei den kopiervorgang gibt es
veränderungen in der erbinformation wie
sehr können die dazu führen dass
impfstoffe auf einmal nicht mehr wirksam
sein können weil eine neue virus ab da
ist ist das schon beobachtet worden muss
man damit rechnen gibt es also relevante
variationen die frage an herrn doktor
müller
sie kennen die klage die vor ungefähr
einer woche leiter von von klinik labors
erhoben haben die sich nicht in der lage
sehen ihre labors an die wahren app zu
koppeln weil die kosten zu hoch seien im
sechsstelligen bereich unterstützen sie
die forderung der kollegen dass hier
eine finanzielle unterstützung oder
förderung durch den bund hilfreich oder
nötig wäre
damit dieses tool überhaupt auf den
klinik- labors eingesetzt werden kann
dann gehe ich doch mal los dieses virus
hat ja ein erbgut und das besteht aus
30.000 buchstaben und im prozess wo es
diese buchstaben kopiert das kann man
sich wie beim kopiervorgang tatsächlich
vorstellen passieren fehler
und es ist bei viren sehr
unterschiedlich manche machen sehr wenig
fehler andere machen total viele fehler
und bringe die buchstaben komplett
durcheinander wie zum beispiel das
influenza-virus und dann gibt es hier in
diese so liegen so dazwischen und dieses
corona virus macht fehler
da werden buchstaben ausgetauscht das
ist richtig aber bislang wurde nicht
beobachtet dass es sich dadurch in
seinen eigenschaften sehr stark
verändert hat das hat es ganz am anfang
mal zu beginn der pandemie gab es da
eine veränderung dass es sich eher
leichter übertragen hat im moment sieht
man da keine großen veränderungen ja da
war ja auch teilweise vielleicht die
hoffnung auch in dem land gehen die
zahlen hoch weil das virus was da
passiert ist vielleicht infektiöser als
hier in deutschland
dem ist nicht so es verhält sich in
europa
ziemlich ähnlich impfstoffe da würde ich
auch gerne eine entwarnung geben also
wir gehen davon aus dass die impfstoffe
dich jetzt entwickelt werden
dieses virus auch wirklich noch gut in
schach halten können dass die die
häufigkeit wie es sich verändert nicht
so stark ist dass die nicht mehr greifen
können habe ich das gut erklärt vielen
dank für die frage die die anbindung an
die korona warnend auf der technischen
seite ist durchaus komplex krankenhäuser
wie größere laboratorien gehören per
gesetz zur kritischen infrastruktur
haben also er ganz erhebliche
anforderungen zu erfüllen was das thema
it sicherheit datenschutz und auch
kommunikation sicherheit angeht dass es
in größeren stationären einheiten
nochmal komplexer weil dort ganz
unterschiedliche netzwerke miteinander
kommunizieren das nur zu einer ordnung
auch des unterschiedlichen aufwandes
durchaus und im rahmen der korona vanek
spielt hier eine rolle die sogenannte
user id mit dem befund in das system zu
implementieren dafür muss sich die ju
die zur verfügung haben und mit
entsprechenden systems kennen damit ich
sie über das labor informationssystem
werden der zu untersuchte zugestimmt hat
auch übermitteln können das ist ganz
unterschiedlich komplex
selbstverständlich ist es immer gut wenn
bei der bei den finanziellen
aufwendungen bei der umsetzung dieser
struktur unterstützung da ist dass es
gar keine frage und vielleicht muss man
das auch ein bisschen differenziert
sehen
die meisten laboratorien haben auch hier
durchaus fünfstellige investitionen zu
machen haben und dann wird man das
sicherlich in den diskussionen in der
nächsten zeit vielleicht nochmal zu
besprechen haben
unterstützen sie die forderung dass ich
denke dass man das differenziert zu
sehen hat und wie ich schon gerade sagt
natürlich ist es immer gut wenn es
unterstützung gibt wir haben darüber als
verband auch ganz zu anfang gesprochen
hätten haben uns das auch gewünscht
allein daran würde man das nicht
scheitern denn am ende des tages ist die
installation und sage ich mal die
umsetzung dieser dieser arbeit eine
mögliche die stationären wie ambulanten
operateuren haben mit verschiedenen
arbeitsgruppen daran mitgewirkt wie
diese technische umsetzung sein kann wie
das erfolgen kann so dass auch unsere
unsere hinweise durchaus gehört worden
sind dann hätte ich nächste frage
vielen dank für roland neumann vom zdf
ersparen dann die frage heute morgen gab
es ebenfalls die meldung von herrn
ganzen dass es große zweifel gibt an der
zahl der tatsächlich frei verfügbaren
und belegbaren intensivbetten also eben
nicht so gut 8000 die als zahl genannt
ist wie scheint liegt uns dass die wie
ihre gäste eine falsche sicherheit und
was für eine schlussfolgerung ziehen sie
daraus eine zweite höhere nachfrage an
herrn professor schade zum thema erwehrt
sie haben den rückgang geschrieben den
es in den letzten tagen zu sehen gab
haben sie eine erklärung dafür ist dass
bereits eine verhaltensänderung der
menschen die sich da in der schlecht
eventuell zum die wie register mit ich
wenn sie einverstanden würde herrn
jansons aber tatsächlich bitten weil das
die wii register schon dem namen nach
eines auch ist das mit dem verband der
intensivmediziner entwickelt und wurde
und betrieben wird
unsere verordnung sieht sehr klar vor
und so würde ich es noch immer
verstanden haben dass es um betten geht
die nicht nur in der technischen
ausstattung und beatmungsgerät vorhanden
sind sondern tatsächlich auch betreiber
weil personal vorhanden ist mein
eindruck ist dass auch viele
krankenhäuser das so gehandhabt haben
aber eben nicht alle
und wir haben im übrigen auch zwei
kategorien eigentlich auch dort
vorgesehen gehabt nämlich eben regelhaft
betreibt war und wie viel wäre
eigentlich noch zusätzlich betreibt
darunter sozusagen notfall mechanismen
wenn man eben geschultes personal das
ist ja auch in vielen krankenhäusern
personal geschult worden den letzten
monaten um einspringen zu können wenn es
wirklich knapp würde in einer echten
notsituation da sind wir noch lange
nicht stand heute und wollen vermeiden
dass wir dahin kommen
aber wir haben jetzt schon diese zwei
kategorien und deswegen setze ich schon
jetzt auch darauf herr janssens das
sozusagen die ehre der intensiven
medizin dahin auch führt dass dieses
register tatsächlich
widerspiegelt wie die tatsächliche
versorgungslage einfach ist und was
tatsächlich betreibt war ist nicht wir
können nicht jeden tag in jedes
krankenhaus doch gehen und das
kontrollieren wie soll das gehen
am ende müssen wir uns verlassen können
darauf dass dort korrekte angaben
gemacht werden
aus meinem eindruck heraus haben auch
die allermeisten ein hohes interesse
daran und tun das und da wo das aus
welchen gründen auch immer
da gibt es ja spekulationen aller art ob
es finanzielle oder sonstige gründe hat
nicht passiert sein sollte ist mein
eindruck findet gerade der
anpassungsprozess stadt darf da
vielleicht kurz dazu noch was sagen dass
die intensiv register ist tatsächlich
das darf man daher stellen noch mal
sagen deshalb darf man das auch nicht
jetzt
pessimistisch sehen das ist wirklich
weltweit einmalig das muss man schon
sagen wir haben wirklichen überblick wir
sehen wie viel co ed bastian welle
liegen habe das ist wirklich klar und
wir haben von anfang an die definition
klar den kollegen mit gezeigt und sind
wirklich dabei im moment noch mal klar
nachzustellen und noch mal sogar
persönlich wirklich in die zentren
reinzugehen posa kinesis der einer der
leiter ist und professor steffen weber
karstens hier aus der charité geht
telefonieren mit den häusern machen noch
einmal völlig klar dass uns ist
besonders wichtig ist dass man nicht
betten jetzt tatsächlich als freie
deklariert die zu dem zeitpunkt wo sie
es ein gemisch fall sind komme aber ich
kann ihnen versichern dass wir genügend
intensivbetten haben und wenn wir ihn
ein umschichten prozess gehen in deinen
um schlichtungsprozess gehen werden wir
auch das personal tatsächlich dafür zur
verfügung haben deshalb die ängste die
da vielleicht mit verbunden sind und sie
haben in ihrer frage nur die hälfte
meines kommentars von heute morgen
wieder gegeben dann werden wir das auch
tatsächlich stemmen und deshalb will ich
an dieser stelle noch mal in versichern
dass wir an den dingen dran sind und
zwar ganz klar auch mit der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft haben gestern
nochmals ein brief herausgeschickt und
alle noch mal klar zu verdeutlichen wie
wichtig das ist aber sie werden sehen
dass wir am ende des prozesses die
versorgung der kogit 19 nicht gewinnt 19
patienten gewährleisten können das ist
meine ganz klare fest überzeugen und die
zweite frage ging
ja also wir vorweg vielleicht noch mal
möchte ich noch mal ganz klar sagen ob
dieser leicht sinken der er bei den
letzten tagen ob das jetzt ein stabiler
trend ist oder nicht oder eine
schwankung das kann zur zeit noch keiner
sagen
solche schwankungen hat es auch früher
schon öfter mal gegeben über einige tage
das wird sich erst in der in den
nächsten tagen dann zeigen in welche
richtung es weitergeht und wie stabil
das ist aber falsch ist stabil sein
sollte wäre das natürlich schon eine
eine ein ausdruck oder ein ergebnis
einer verhaltensänderung und von
maßnahmen wir dürfen bei alldem aber
nicht vergessen dass wir ja maßnahmen
seit wochen und monaten machen und
trotzdem ist dieser erwert zwischendurch
auf diese 1,3 1,4 über eine lange zeit
gestiegen unter den massnahmen das heißt
also um den runter zu kriegen muss man
mehr maßnahmen machen sonst wird diese
geht dieser wert nicht wieder runter und
auf 1 zu kriegen reicht nicht dann haben
wir jeden tag im schnitt 15.000 fälle
was auch zu viel isst er muss also
deutlich unter 1 also muss man dafür
jetzt maßnahmen machen dass es überhaupt
gar keine frage und damit er wieder an
einen bereich kommt den wir
kontrollierbar oder für kontrollierbar
ansehen können
da muss eine ganze zeit deutlich unter 1
1 bei 0,7 vielleicht vielleicht am
besten noch niedriger und auch dann wird
es wochen dauern bis wir wieder in den
bereich kommen von vielleicht 2010 pro
tag
und dann haben wir einen wieder einen
bereich den wir kontrollieren können
also in diesem sinne vielleicht ist das
schon so eine auswirkung von
verhaltensänderungen aber ob das so ist
ist unklar und wir brauchen auf jeden
fall eine deutliche reduktion des
erwehrt wir gehen mit ihnen fragen auf
die von uns aus gesehen rechte seite
handy barney hat die nächsten zwei
fragen eine nachfrage zu dem komplex
krankenhauses planbare operation im
frühjahr gab es einen klaren beschluss
von bund und ländern
im rahmen der konferenz die planbaren
operationen sind verschieden dann
sozusagen abgestimmt entscheiden und wir
sind gilt es jetzt schulen weil sie
berichteten von der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz
und wenn es das nicht gibt darum gilt es
bislang noch nicht
und die zweite frage an professor schade
ihr präsident hat vor 14 tagen in einer
pressekonferenz relativ detailliert
berichtet wo ja die infektionsherde
sieht und hat da sagt also viele
bereiche sind eben nicht infektionsherde
wie zum beispiel mit ruhe und eine woche
später ist dann das passiert was eben
passiert ist von merkel hat sehr
detailliert dargelegt dass die summe der
einzelteile ist und hat diese zahl von
75 cent nicht verfolgbar infektion in
den raum stellt können sie mir erklären
warum hat wieder eine woche davor dass
andere frage also zum ersten was die
frage angeht der verschiebung von
operationen sind wir im moment in einer
phase wo aus unserer sicht und da hat
der ernst ja auch darauf hingewiesen es
vor allem auch geht das regional
abhängig von der lage zu machen
wir haben sehr unterschiedliche
situation auch in der belastung und
auslastung der intensivmediziner aktuell
weil ja auch die infektionszahlen
regional durchaus immer noch
unterschiede haben in den letzten wochen
unterschiede haben
es gab jetzt zwei beschlüsse der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ich glaube
am mitte oktober war es unter ziffer 14
wenn ich es richtig erinnere die zuerst
einmal die verantwortung auch der länder
die auch da ist objektiv ich kann aus
dem grund heraus
die kapazitäten regional nicht steuern
sondern das ist eben landes
verantwortung ist aber auch gemeinsames
verständnis das ist das ist für die
länder beschriebener zur steuerung und
gleichzeitig wir als bund eben dass die
wii register und tatsächlich das erlebe
ich auch im gespräch mit den
europäischen kollegen und kollegen schon
relativ einmalig
in dieser form als grund entwickelt
haben und jetzt eben in den finanziellen
absicherungen die maßnahmen besprechen
und gegebenenfalls ergänzend umsetzen
das steuern los auf landesebene und
regional lageangepasst geschehen und das
tut es ja auch und das tut es noch
leichter wenn ebendiese finanzieller
liquiditäts und absicherungs thematik
von uns zeitnah aufgelöst wird
ja also ich glaube eigentlich nicht dass
es eine diskrepanz herr villa hat die
daten vorgestellt oder die infektions
orte für die fälle wo uns diese
information bekannt ist und das sind
eben nur von denen uns gemeldeten
verändern etwa 25 prozent das heißt also
von 75 prozent wissen wir es nicht von
denen dies angegeben haben hat sich das
halt so verteilt wie damals von herrn
wieder vorgestellt das sind die daten
die uns bekannt sind und die da für uns
eben auch verpflichtet die dann
entsprechend auch vorzustellen mit der
einordnung dass das nur natürlich nur
geht für den teil der gemeldeten fälle
wo diese information vorhanden ist aus
welchen gründen auch immer
zum beispiel weil die patienten sich
nicht erinnern zum beispiel war das aus
irgendwelchen gründen nicht eingetragen
ist man kann sich nie an alle ansteckung
orte erinnern das wird nie passieren
dass sich alle an alle ansteckung orte
erinnern und es gibt eben auch innerhalb
dieser ansteckung sorte unterschiedlich
gut erinnern also wenn man irgendwo zur
feier waren da sind viele kranke ist
klar und man weiß dass dann kann man das
gut erinnern
wenn man sich im zug oder irgendwo
anders angesteckt haben sollte alle
personen darauf an auseinander man kennt
ihn nicht man hat die information nicht
was mit den anderen passiert dass
weniger gute änderbar
also all das sind dinge die man
letztendlich zur einordnung ergeben auch
dazu sagen muss aber ich sehe da
eigentlich keine diskrepanz von 75
prozent wissen wir es eben nicht und von
den anderen verhält sich sie dargestellt
vielen dank ich hab ne frage an frau
brinkmann und zwar und einfach an das
lka die größte politische neue
prioritätensetzung war ja dass schulen
und kitas dieses mal wirklich offen
bleiben sollen
vielleicht können sie mir aus
biologischer sicht sagen wie sie das
einschätzen ist das eine richtige
entscheidung oder eine gefährliche und
beim rk ist es ja so dass hier zumindest
durchaus andere vorstellungen vom
präsenzunterricht haben als es heute in
vielen bundesländern stattfindet mit
stichwort situation über 50 beim
incidents wert wie bewerten sie diese
politische entscheidung
ja die schulfrage ist immer wieder ein
schwieriges thema natürlich kommt es zur
ansteckung in der schule keiner sagt
dass es dort zu keinen ansteckungen
kommt die frage ist kommt es dort zu
sehr vielen ansteckungen und ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin sehr
erleichtert dass die kinder jetzt im
unterricht masken tragen denn dadurch
ihn verhindern wir werden wir einige
sind infektionen verhindern vor allem
auch weil die schulen ja auch ein ort
sind wo das mit dem lüften tatsächlich
ganz gut klappt egal wie sehr das von
manchen eltern nicht gern gesehen wird
weil es kalt ist aber es es vermindert
das infektionsrisiko ist die kombination
von den masten im unterricht die ja zum
einen verhindern dass sich den schüler
der tatsächlich neben mir setzt weil die
abstände nicht eingehalten werden kann
die maske kann dieses risiko dass ich
meinen nachbarn anstecke deutlich
reduzieren
die kann aber auch die übertragen die
übertragung über aerosole reduzieren
denn viren die schwören ja nicht frei in
der luft herum die sind immer hängen
immer irgendwas dran an den tröpfchen
die wir gerade ausscheiden ja hatte ich
gerade vermehrt ausscheiden vor sich hin
will die werden aber durch die maske
zurückgehalten ja die viren sind
unheimlich klein die würden da ganz gut
noch durchkommen aber die tröpfchen in
denen die sind die wir werden durch die
maske abgehalten sprich ich reduziere
die menge an viruspartikeln die in der
luft herum schwirren
das ist gut ich reduziere es nicht
komplett das ist wie beim einem
schweizer käse modell die maske ist
nicht perfekt die hat auch ihren
ja aber die die reduziert schon mal
ungemein und ich bin ich sage es noch
mal heilfroh dass es jetzt gekommen es
in den schulen so und dann haben wir
noch das thema lüften die luft wird
ausgetauscht und ich glaube dass das
infektionsrisiko dadurch wirklich
deutlich reduziert sind weitere vorteile
von den schulen es die haben ihre festen
kurorten und die kinder sitzen alle
immer am selben platz ja das kann sehr
gut nachvollzogen werden zum thema daten
und wir brauchen auch bin ich ganz bei
ihnen wir brauchen auch mehr daten
einfach um zu verstehen sowie vier
infektionen kommt denn jetzt eigentlich
in den schulen
das ist ein bisschen versäumt worden da
brauchen wir noch mehr
dazu gehört natürlich auch die sehr gute
kontakt nachverfolgung und von daher
halte ich es für wirklich die
allerletzte maßnahme die man treffen
muss um wenn nehmen wir mal die zahlen
gehen jetzt nicht so runter wie wir uns
das wünschen wie er schade dass grad
dargestellt hat dann wird wird die
nächste konsequenz sein wir werden das
länger durchziehen müssen oder wir
müssen weitere maßnahmen einführen
und da wollen wir nicht hin ja aber ich
bin ziemlich zuversichtlich dass das mit
der einführung der masken jetzt wirklich
ganz gut unter kontrolle kommt dreht mal
aus von mir selbst ich bin mutter von
drei kindern
die kommen jeden tag nach hause und ich
werden teufel tun und die jetzt sechs
monate nicht in arm nehmen und nicht
abgerufen ja und jedes mal denke ich der
kleene könnte gerade infiziert sein und
mich anstecken und ich gebe es weiter
ich mir geht es tatsächlich besser
erhaltene maske trägt wie geht's einfach
besser denn das risiko ist so deutlich
minimiert dass ich damit ganz gut leben
kann habe ich viel geredet habe ich die
frage beantworte ich glaube ja
zwei kindern schadet ja das robert koch
institut gibt gibt empfehlungen nach
nach dem fachlichen stand und so wie es
das unterrichtung der entsprechende
literatur und auch austausch mit anderen
experten für sinnvoll hält ich wir haben
volles verständnis dafür dass man unter
berücksichtigung anderer aspekte
pädagogische organisatorischer und so
weiter diese empfehlungen anpassen will
und auch teilweise anpassen muss damit
es letztendlich funktioniert bei sich in
der schule aber ich denke man muss auch
schon einfach klar dazu sagen
man muss was tun ansonsten wird es zu
infektionen kommen in der schule die
infektion in der schule das ist jetzt
kein besonderer herd die besonders stark
applizieren die die pandemie aber die
schüler vor allen dingen die eltern sind
genauso betroffen wie alle anderen auch
und die kommen täglich zusammen da wird
es zu infektionen kommen es gibt auch
ausbrüche und man muss entsprechend
maßnahmen treffen wenn man diese
ausbrüche verhindern will
und je weniger und je mehr man das ab
schichtet um so mehr geht man dieses
risiko letztendlich ein ja mehr im
übrigen wenn ich das erinnern darf die
schweiz geht die auch geleitet haben der
pressekonferenz wo frau gefallen und ich
vorletzten freitag glaube ich war es ja
die ergebnisse entschuldigung studie
vorgestellt hatten
wo wir sehen das war ja der befund ist
es nicht infektions treiber aber es ist
natürlich bestandteil des infektions
geschehens in der gesellschaft ein
wichtiger unterschied
und dass man vor allem mit dem was wir
bis jetzt an erkenntnissen haben dass
vor allem die jüngeren kinder kita und
grundschule noch viel weniger
bestandteil des infektionsgeschehen sind
als es dann ab 13 14 jährig wird das ist
der informations- oder wissensstand aus
den studien den wir an der stelle bis
jetzt haben aber klar ist die schulen
sind natürlich wenn das
infektionsgeschehen der gesellschaft
steigt davon nicht unbetroffen aber
wichtig ist die bisherigen
erkenntnislage sind nicht treiber das
infektionsgeschehen soder verteilt sind
sozusagen das infektionsgeschehen ist
denke ich jedenfalls mit dem wissenstand
heute wichtig ich würde versuchen dass
wir noch drei kurze fragen schaffen das
sind laut meiner liste frau bei der
jungen und hering frau berheide vielen
dank aber wer hätte deutsches ärzteblatt
ich hätte eine frage an herrn müller
wenn die anti gen test jetzt zusätzlich
zu den pc erst es kommt was ist das für
ein zeitlicher im arbeits
arbeitsentlastung ja eigentlich erst für
die labore wenn da jetzt mehr auf der
schiene sozusagen mit in das geschehen
hinein kommt und dann verbringt man sie
hatten ja kritisiert dass es viele
vorschläge gibt jetzt was sozusagen
sowie die sommerzeit im sommer fand wie
mit falschen diskussion sozusagen
verschwendet haben was sind denn ihre
vorschläge für die zeit ab dezember
januar februar und so weiter vielen
herzlichen dank für die frage die anti
gen tests haben zwei möglichkeiten im
rahmen der nationalen strategie kann ich
sie einsetzen wenn ich schnell eine
entscheidung braucht jemand mit fieber
husten geht in die praxis hat sich dort
vorher angemeldet und es ist hat
vielleicht auch kontakt gehabt da kann
die kann diese anti gen test eingesetzt
werden um zu türmen zu belegen dass das
vielleicht eine kurve 19 erkrankung ist
er wird dann nochmals zu bestätigen
seien weil wir auch bei den anti gen
test falsch positive sehen hilft aber
den kranken menschen direkt in die
isolation zubringen
auf der anderen seite kann ich bei
pflegeheim altenheimen da wo ich
eigentlich erwartet dass die besucher
symptomatisch also ohne symptome ihrer
angehörigen besuchen wollen durch
häufigeres testen den eintrag von
infektionen in dieses pflegeheim den
kann ich besser kontrollieren
das würde sehr helfen die pcr
kapazitäten in den laboren zu entlassen
denn wir sind wie ich vorhin sagte bei
100 prozent und brauchen eine redaktion
ich sag nur reduktion gut um ein drittel
denn bei weiterem exponentiellen
wachstum ist jeder test den wir
zusätzlich als pcr machen soll natürlich
nur dann möglich wenn wir in der anderen
in anderen fragen tatsächlich reduzieren
und das werden wir unterstützen mit den
anti gen tests im labor die wir uns
jetzt gerade angucken um dann dort
helfen zu können wo beispielsweise in
einer pflegerin
ein altenheim einrichtung das
durchführende es vor ort auf kante
genäht ist das vielleicht schwierig ist
weil die infrastruktur nicht da ist denn
es sollen ja fach medizinisches
fachpersonal diese tests durchführen was
wichtig und richtig ist und insofern
können wir da noch helfen dass wir gehen
davon aus dass über die einführung und
vor allen dingen auch über die
fokussierung der test regierung der
testkriterien er professor schade ist
vorhin gesagt hat wir zu einer
deutlichen reduktion der pcr test um
kommen können was wichtig wäre
ich antworte mal ganz schnell wegen der
zeit einmal glaube ich ist viel luft
nach oben bei der schnelligkeit der
kontakt nach verfolgung stichwort
digitalisierung dann auch schnellere
testmethoden da sind wir jetzt mit den
anti gen test zum guten schritt
vorangekommen
aber auch da ist noch entwicklungsbedarf
aber das ist alles nicht so hopplahopp
machbar aber da sehe ich so ein paar
lichtblicke am tunnel ja da werden wir
besser werden
aber jetzt ist es denke ich wichtig zu
sagen wie können wir schneller werden
bei der kontakt nach verfolgung denn das
wir werden wieder an dieses limit kommen
ja und ich glaube was man auch klar
sagen muss wir werden mit vielen
einschränkungen weiter leben müssen wir
werden die masken weiter tragen wir
werden im ostern mit der pandemie nicht
durch sein ja und auch da sich
entwicklung bei der massenherstellung
dass wir bessere masken bekommen für
kinder zum beispiel gibt es jetzt auch
welche die auf den markt gehen und vor
allem die sollten auch zertifiziert
seien ja nicht dass leute irgendwie
meldet endlich sagen jetzt nicht wo aber
weiß ich überhaupt ob die funktionieren
ja da ist glaube ich auch noch viel
potenzial und was glaube ich auch
wichtig ist sind noch klare richtlinien
bei hygiene konzepten dass betriebe
wirklich verstehen wenn mein laden
weiterlaufen soll muss sich hier hygiene
konzepte wirklich auch durchsetzen das
ist wichtig dass man die nicht nur an
die wand hängt so macht bitte sondern
dass es auch wirklich gelebt wird in dem
betrieb da ist glaube ich noch viel herr
jung
wenn man kurz ersparen es gab während
dieser pk die meldung dass die groko
sich auf eine weitere
parlamentsbeteiligung einigt hätte und
dass er noch im november ein gesetz zur
pandemie kommen soll können sie das
bestätigen und das ausführen und frau
bringt man wie finden sie ist als
biologin dass es keine aha regeln in der
bahn im bus und dem flugzeug gibt also
wenn ich fliege muss ich neben meinem
nachbarn sitzen und es ist keine reihe
freigelassen sowie die asa dba oder dass
er empfiehlt wenn ich dann hier berlin
fall sind die meistens sogar voll das
ist doch eigentlich ein infektionsherd
regeln gelten überall dass wenn dann
geht es eher oder regeln um ein
unabhängig davon was die frage angeht
des gesetzentwurfes ich kennen die
meldungen jetzt nicht auf die sie sich
beziehen
ich weiß nur eins er mit sie nicht dann
weiß ich worum es geht nämlich dass beim
dritten bevölkerungsschutz gesetz das ja
neben dem kabinettsbeschluss auch durch
die fraktion in den bundestag
eingebracht werden soll und am freitag
in erster lesung um 9 uhr gelesen werden
soll es auch zu änderungen beim
paragrafen 28 ford folgende gibt der
regelt die verordnungsermächtigung für
die länder die so wie es ja auch die
debatte der letzten wochen immer wieder
zurecht aufgegriffen hat konkretisiert
werden sollen bezogen auf die maßnahmen
die ergriffen werden also tatsächlich
neben der allgemeinen kalt klausel
generalklausel § 28 ist für diese
pandemie und mit den maßnahmen die wir
in dieser pandemie ergreifen eine
konkretisierung nicht nur die
generalklausel sondern konkreteres
benennen innovativ auch möglicher
maßnahmen im infektionsschutzgesetz
geben soll
die fraktionen beraten heute nachmittag
darüber und wenn es so kommt wie wie es
über licht haben dann würde das
bestandteil der ersten
am freitag und der zweiten dritten
lesung in der nächsten sitzungswoche
brinkmann zu den vollen verkehrsmittel
jahr zum vollen flieger also im sinne
des klima wandelt se besser weniger zu
fliegen und wer nicht unbedingt fliegen
muss bleibt vielleicht einfach besser zu
hause in der nächsten zeit und gerade im
winter ich würde das gern noch mal
betonen der winter stellt uns wirklich
vor große herausforderungen
dieses virus ist es einfach leichter uns
zu infizieren im winter aus vielerlei
gründen die ich auch gern nochmal ruhe
erläutere probleme sind immer
situationen wo ich die maske abnehmen
beim fliegen zum beispiel wenn gerade
alle gleichzeitig essen und die maske
abnehmen und dann auch munter vielleicht
sich noch unterhalten keine gute idee da
muss es irgendwie dann auch für
langstreckenflüge eine idee geben dass
man das essen vielleicht nicht
gleichzeitig aus teilt auch wenn manche
leute dann unglücklich sein werden aber
da muss es dann pragmatische lösungen
geben die maske hilft uns sehr viel
sie hilft uns nicht komplett in den
fliegern ist tatsächlich eine sehr gute
lüftung vorhanden
er gibt es beispiele für übertragung
aber die sind relativ gering ich glaub
wo es dann wieder kritisch wird es eine
situation wo man einsteigen muss ja dann
macht man die lüftung des flugzeuges
vielleicht schon an werden die leute
sich ihren platz suchen
und weil es jetzt die zeit um ist höre
ich jetzt einfach auf war das okay für
sie waren ja habe ich heute auch gedacht
also meint super tatsächlich sehr leer
und wenn man jetzt man sollte sich
vielleicht überlegen muss ich wirklich
zur hauptzeit fahren kann ich meinen tag
und wie anders organisieren dass ich
nicht fahren wenn diese bahn voll ist
und tatsächlich die kontakt beschränkung
jetzt führt er dazu dass die leute sich
weniger bewegen das ist ja genau das was
wir erreichen wollen dass die züge
weniger gefüllt sind dann eine
allerletzte frage bitte kurz von den
linken
ja ganz kurze frage an frau bringt man
so ein schweizer käse und den löchern
die slowakei führt schnelltests für die
gesamte bevölkerung durch ist das
sinnvoll ja oder nein
und herr sparende sie haben brände sowie
wirkstoffe jetzt weiter angefordert es
gibt aber in der studie die sagt ja dass
der wirkstoff weitgehend wirkungslos
sein soll also warum haben sie das
nachgestellt ist das sinnvoll das
problem mit dem schnelltest ist es der
ist der hat ein sehr geringes
haltbarkeitsdatum ja und wenn ich jetzt
hier bin ich jetzt irgendeine
bevölkerung so und so viele sind nicht
infiziert das heißt nicht dass die am
nächsten tag nicht doch positiv sind
aber es ist eine momentaufnahme die mir
sagt wie schlecht steht es gerade
eigentlich um uns ja um auch die
dunkelziffer etwas vielleicht zu ja zu
erfassen
aber es ist ein situation da sollten wir
hier nicht hinkommen ja die haben da
wirklich ganz andere probleme gerade und
das ist so ein verzweifelter akt in
meinen augen
wie sehen sie das
ich sehe das ganz ehrlich das ist
tatsächlich nur eine momentaufnahme der
dauert noch einige tage bis alle
getestet werden können und wir wissen
das ja dass ein negativer test ohne
einen klaren zusammenhang und ein anlass
nur für den moment gültig ist und am
nächsten tag kann die situation anders
sein deswegen anders bezogene test und
das ist verständlich da nur die frau
bringt man das sagt ein den versuch für
einen moment den überblick zu gewinnen
wer betroffen ist und wer in diesem
moment nicht betroffen ist im übrigen
wenn sie das bei 80 millionen bewohnern
machen wollen würden in deutschland
würde es so viele tage dauern das der
aussagewert wahrscheinlich ein sehr
überschaubarer dann tatsächlich ist
zumal wer nicht abgeschlossen vom rest
leben wenn ich aus dem alltag nur auch
sagen darf ich glaube ich mache schon
noch mal ein unterschied das ist ja
alles am ende relativ das ist ja das was
schweizer käse bild sozusagen gesagt mit
dem nüchtern wir haben mit jeder
maßnahme die wir machen eine relative
aber keine absolute sicherheit nicht
zusätzlich und umso mehr relative
sicherheiten wir hintereinander lägen
desto mehr verschließen wir löcher
sozusagen und haben erhöhte sicherheit
und in der u-bahn ist eine ganz andere
situation als im restaurant also den
allermeisten dann verhalten sich dann
nicht groß sondern schauen auf ihr handy
auf ihr buch überlegen vielleicht
der tag noch für sie bringt und es
dauert meistens nicht mag beim
langstrecken anders sein aber zwei bis
drei stunden und deswegen finde ich muss
man auch jede situation und dann auch
ihre notwendigkeit der weg zur arbeit
mag von höherer notwendigkeit sein als
die partie jedenfalls für die
allermeisten und deswegen glaube ich ist
es am ende immer in dieser
gesamtabwägung und betrachtung
hinzusehen absolute sicherheit gibt es
tatsächlich nicht ramsey wir haben wir
tatsächlich zusätzlich besorgt als
übrigens bis jetzt einzig zugelassen ist
als neunzehnter ist aber antivirale
medikament ist macht es sinn zu
bestimmten phasen insbesondere des
infektionsverlauf es zugeben nicht zu
jeder und ein teil der vero studie die
dann öffentlich wurde dann in der
überschrift verkürzt das macht in
bestimmten phasen keinen sinn rem diese
wir noch einzusetzen
es macht aber nicht überhaupt keinen
sinn sondern für bestimmte situationen
da kann der intensivmediziner aber im
zweifel noch medizinisch ergänzend was
zu sagen weil es aber eben in bestimmten
situationen sinn macht und der bedarf
enorm gestiegen ist in deutschland haben
wir zusätzlich tatsächlich mdc bier
geordert
wir haben das auch sehr kritisch für
unsere vierte version so intensiv
leitlinien noch mal angeschaut des the
devil you try worauf sie sich da
beziehen von der wehr ist bisher noch
nicht fertig oder selbst noch nicht
genau durch gesehen worden es ist auf
ein server gelegt worden und das ist für
uns schon grund so dass zumindest
kritisch zu sehen und wir verlassen uns
auch im moment auf die daten der acg 1
studie und wir denken auch dass die
substanz sehr früh gegeben werden muss
wie da wird verbringt man mir mit
sicherheit zur seite springen das macht
tatsächlich die antivirale substanz sinn
in der frühphase und da wollen wir auch
den englischen amerikanischen daten wo
wir sagen da hat es tatsächlich die
krankheitsdauer verkürzt und tatsächlich
ist eine hilfe und deshalb werden wir
auch in der aktuellen kommenden version
und immer noch dafür aussprechen wir
werden aber kritisch die daten dann
überprüfen wenn sie endlich vollständig
geregelt publiziert
wir leben über ramsey wir wie bei
schnelltests wie bei allem anderen auch
es gibt eine weltweite nachfrage
gleichzeitig von allen und selbst und
jeder rem diese dose kümmern wir uns
sehr intensiv dass
die uns hier in deutschland erreicht und
ich bin sehr froh dass wir diese
zusätzlichen dosen nun sichern können es
tut mir leid für alle die mit ihren
zweiten fragen nicht mehr rangekommen
sind es wird vielleicht noch eine
weitere gelegenheit zu einem anderen
zeitpunkt geben daher danke ich unseren
gästen fürs kommen dank die infos kommen
ähnliche pressekonferenz